chaque repas dans la famille charara est
affaire de patience et d'affection
wissam père d'une famille monoparentale
doit nourrir sa fille une bouchée à la
fois mada à un double diagnostic de
déficience intellectuelle et d'autisme
elle vient tout juste d'avoir 21 ans
pensez pas quoi faire après le 21 ans
après septembre 21 ans et la fin du
parcours scolaire pour les autistes
déficients intellectuels et pour les
parents comme wissem charara celle
angoisse il faut trouver des activités
et des services pour leurs enfants
maintenant adultes sans être autonome et
on ne sait pas quand on pas trouver on
peut trouver une place pour elle ils
m'ont dit en novembre mais issam charaf
doit trouver un centre de jour pour sa
fille sinon il devra fermer son garage
une entreprise qui fonctionne déjà au
ralenti parce qu'ils consacrent beaucoup
de temps à sa fille handicapée
j'arrive tout le temps fatigué de jour
en jour
je ne peux pas travailler 40 heures
geneviève béliveau trisomique de 39 ans
adore son père claude b niveau qui s'est
toujours battu pour qu'elles aient des
services il est coauteur d'un rapport
sur les services en autisme et en
déficience intellectuelle et les
attendra demain nous ayons atteint un
niveau là que moi juge absolument
inacceptable et honteux et environ 4400
personnes à l'échelle du québec qui
attendent un premier service le premier
service c'est le premier contact avec un
professionnel comme par exemple
psychologue ou un ergothérapeute pour la
période allant de 2014 à 2018 le nombre
de personnes en attente de ce premier
service a augmenté de 39% en déficience
intellectuelle pour l'autisme
la hausse est de 51% est-ce que j'ai
besoin de dire que je suis contente de
déposer le plan d'action pourtant
l'ancien gouvernement a investi 29
millions de plus annuellement pour
réduire la tente en autisme la situation
s'est stabilisée dans certaines régions
mais
ailleurs comme à montréal plusieurs
familles attendent encore plus d'un on
peut atteindre jusqu'à 3 400 500 jours
dépendamment des régions pour un premier
service pour un enfant qui est de
l'autisme les budgets d'un secteur
augmente mais de manière moins rapide
que le nombre de diagnostic d'autisme
qui a été multiplié par 4 entre 2000 et
la famille charara a finalement trouvé
une demi journée d'activités cinq fois
par semaine pour mada là aussi
l'offre est limitée en ce moment 64% des
personnes ayant une déficience
intellectuelle ou un trouble du spectre
de l'autisme honte excès à une activité
de jour ou à du soutien l'intégration au
travail
on est encore loin de l'objectif établi
par le gouvernement libéral qui était de
90% très beau faire ajourner geneviève
elle profite toujours d'un milieu de
stage en vertu d'un programme
gouvernemental
elle aime ce travail dans un restaurant
du nord de montréal qu'elle occupe
depuis presque vingt ans chez moi même a
donné et rien avant faute réveille comme
toulon son père s'inquiète du déclin de
ce type de programme et comme plusieurs
parents d'autistes et de trisomiques
il vit une angoisse qui augmente avec
les années c'est d'angoissé pour savoir
ce qui va arriver une fois qu'on soit
plus là on n'a pas de réponse claire
on n'a pas l'impression que l'état va
prendre en charge adéquate mais les
personnes qu'on va laisser derrière nous
et ça c'est une grande grande souffrance
pour l'epr
[Musique]
et on les comprend les parrains david
est inquiet par ailleurs le gouvernement
de la caq 10 et monsieur legault là
beaucoup répété moi mon premier objectif
est d'augmenter le dépistage chez les
enfants dont le dépistage précoce si on
a des pistes encore plus est ce que ça
risque pas encore d'alourdir ses listes
d'attentes ouais c'est une question
effectivement qu'on peut se poser
patrice et s'est soulevée par certaines
des sources que j'ai consultés dans
l'élaboration la préparation de ce
reportage
mais les gens qui sont au fait justement
des problématiques d'autisme et de
déficience intellectuelle disent aussi
qu'il y primordial d'intervenir
rapidement dans ce secteur lors que si
on n'intervient entre large 2 0 et 12
ans il ya bien des gens atteints de
déficiences intellectuelles ou encore de
certaines formes d'autisme qui peuvent
devenir plus autonomes une fois qu'ils
seront adultes qui peut même contribuer
de manière beaucoup plus importante que
si on n'intervient pas alors qu'ils sont
enfants donc en bout de ligne de faire
de la prévention
les spécialistes auxquels nous le parent
nous le disent c'est véritablement le
bon geste à faire et c'est payant à long
terme de le faire on n'a pas pu obtenir
pour l'instant de réaction du
gouvernement de la caq à ce reportage
pour la simple et bonne raison qu'on ne
sait pas encore qui de danielle mccann
ministre de la santé ou de monsieur
lionel carmant ministre délégué sera
responsable des affaires d'autisme et de
déficience intellectuelle
on compte sur vous pour suivre ça bien
sûr merci david